I've never had a colonoscopy partner and
if you're going to have a colonoscopy
partner is there anybody better than
Adam Glassman not exactly a couple's
massage which is something that you
would might do with a partner I didn't
know y'all were this close
if I sneezed if I sneeze something
oh that's Adam Glassman and meat Adam is
from Oprah daily my other job he's our
creative director also a correspondent
for extra getting ready for a
colonoscopy so it's part of a new Oprah
daily special according to the colon
cancer Coalition one in three Americans
are not up to date on their screenings
and that is a very big deal
colonoscopies detect colon cancer the
second deadliest cancer but their
survival rate listen to this is 90
percent when detected at an early stage
So Adam and I got the routine procedure
and recorded the process with some help
from our Dr John lapuke here's an
exclusive first look
how do you feel this way Adam I just
want to be done don't you I just want to
do it now but things were still coming
out this morning they were yeah moving
drips and drabs yeah I think they call
it anal leakage you don't like it so
what's the perfect colon that a person
could have what does that look like okay
good question is there such a thing the
perfect colon is one for me from my
point of view where um the prep has been
done beautifully so that I can actually
look at every millimeter of it and not
have it be covered by debris
and that's what we're calling it these
days debris
I'm nervous just because it's still a
medical procedure but I have faith in my
doctor that's a good start see ya see
you when you're done and we're done Adam
see you on the other side no you don't
want to say that at all right Dr John
labuk is our chief medical correspondent
and a gastro gastroenterologist what are
you a gastroenterologist okay that's
what you are you're better but I think
it's interesting to do it with a
colleague I've never done that before
but I didn't feel awkward I was very
concerned because Adam was 55 and had
never had one before and that's one of
the reasons why we wanted to do this
I've had a few yeah I've never heard of
the buddy system before I think it's a
really good idea because you do feel a
little bit alone especially if there's
no partner in in the apartment or in the
house where you live but it's time to
take the stigma out of it John because
really people need to understand how
crucial it is to get it and the benefits
of getting it yeah and we we can't
emphasize enough when you do this
colonoscopy the the search is for a
polyp yeah these polyps when you find
them are generally benign however they
can be the kind of polyp which over time
can turn into cancer and if you take the
polyp out at that time which you can do
during the colonoscopy instead of
potential actually getting cancer you
don't get cancer so I know people don't
like to do the prep but it's really
really people might be listening and
thinking to themselves it can't be that
simple but you are saying that it is
that exactly they think it can't be that
but you're right about the stigma you
know it's one of the first jokes between
parents and their kids right it's
something to have having to do with
pooping or peeing right and then for
years we can't we don't talk about it
and I I love taboo for some reason it's
taboo but I love that that you know you
were able to talk about it get out Ryan
Reynolds did did it on air and of course
Katie Kirk all those years back and it's
really important to get the get the word
out and the age the age what where are
we now with the age it used to be 50. it
used to be 50 and then what we're seeing
is now it's down to 45 uh if you are at
no increased risk because we were seeing
colon cancer affecting people younger at
a younger and younger age and even
younger if you have a risk factor for
some reason family history or other
things that could increase the risk well
you know why people are uncomfortable
because you're talking about your butt
nobody wants to visualize your butt and
all this stuff involved in that and I do
think we you have to get past that
because you found polyps that day didn't
you yeah well you were clean and you did
a great job
um Adam and I just got rid of permission
from him to say this on air he did have
some polyps um uh one of them a very
small one was the kind which if let
would totally benign if left in could
have potentially over time turned into
cancer and I took it out with a snare
and it's out it's gone it's in a jar in
a Pathology Lab it will never hurt him
again so he gave me permission very
generously he I said can I tell people I
don't want to do it without you
permission he said anything to help and
I think that's a great addict all right
well I'm 42. so I got some time
I'm looking forward to it though now one
segment I'll go with you we'll do the
buddy you guys
hilarious I'm good with it man that
would actually be talking butts about it
that would be very good
thank you for being transparent it's one
of those things that people don't do on
camera exactly right and when you guys
are ready to have a good doctor of
recommend
thank you you watch the full video of
our colonoscopy Journey head to
opordaily.com it's actually pretty
entertaining